how are you come on in
Texas come on in I think tapa everybody
tapa all right just uh I'm going to stay
here here you go hold I'm hold this
stand right
here all right my dad doesn't follow
directions I know it doesn't
matter my dad doesn't follow Direction
so I feel like this is bad it's a couple
Canadians being shot at by an arrow okay
oh no it's okay she does it she knows
exactly what she's doing oh my God raise
it over your head I'm already raise it
over your head I'm already small so I
don't want to be blind too yeah no no a
little bit ow ow ow
ow feel bad you just brought me into
this no no oh oh uhoh uh-oh should I
look away uh wait put it over your head
look at me dad get away from
him
wow great job I'm glad I'm alive well
thank you I need to go thank you thank
you thank you for being here not killing
me all right Jimmy I remember him close
Sophie close like
you I don't want to end up with cedar SI
okay how you do it how I do it I was I
think it was more dangerous to be here
you going to do it with me yeah okay
here I'll why did you stand next to him
dad with your head right next to the
the target don't hurt the
Jew youw better aim don't hurt the two
Jews how I'm when you're doing it don't
move leave it still so what you're
saying is when we're doing it what don't
do what you're doing like right now like
can I just hold it here and just stop is
he can
he yeah like you should probably leave
it in like one spot all right well this
spot you want it in this spot
or
no but but you in this spot or this spot
where what the hell is wrong with my dad
what come on how you're scared no cuz
she's going to go go up and do it dad
stop moving what stop moving stop moving
I'm just trying to find a spot that is
comfortable for
everybody all right that's all is that
good H yeah you got to stop though tell
me when you're going to do it s I will
just tell me when cuz I'm getting a
little
nervous tell me
when okay I'm going to pull it back and
shoot okay don't move hold it still
don't move Jimmy hold it still I got
it all right jersey at and how we did it
hold I to delay what hold that hold that
I'm on a delay so I heard it go but I
didn't see what you you get a picture
we're in the middle of a podcast what
are you doing this is
not Howe Mandel does stuff Sophie dosy
every everybody
sopie whoa you're amazing and we're I'm
not high fiving I think she P Native
American Indian what
jealous monkey monkey in the middle
monkey in the middle monkey in the
middle I'm going to go back into my seat
right
now okay thank you Sophie thank you so
much so
Sophie wish your luck vote for her AGT
fantasy League Monday nights on
NBC we are voting for
[Music]
Sophie